und über dieses urteil aus karlsruhe
kann ich nun sprechen
mit andreas ion er ist stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der union im
bundestag und klimaexperte guten tag
nach stuttgart herr jung guten tag auf
die sicherung okay die reaktionen auf
das klima urteil von gestern die
schwanken ja inzwischen sehr stark die
einen sagen das sei ein längst fälliges
signal gegen die erderwärmung
andere sagen damit sei das
verfassungsgericht der lobby von angeles
und jugend auf den leim gegangen
wie bewerten sie denn das urteil erstmal
respektiere ich selbstverständlich das
hotel ist aufgabe des
verfassungsgerichts zu prüfen ob das was
wir im parlament beschließen mit den
grundrechten mit dem grundgesetz
übereinstimmen
da haben die in vielen punkten gesagt
das ist in ordnung aber in einem
zentralen punkt hätten sie gesagt da
muss nachgebessert werden nämlich bei
der strecke 25-30 zu 2050 bis 20.30 uhr
der sehr detailliert die klimaziele
festgelegt die runtergebrochen auf
sektoren gesagt wenn die nicht erreicht
werden müsse nachgebessert werden
dann hat man aber gesagt danach kommt
das jahr 2050 dann müssen wir
klimaneutralität erreicht haben und des
verfassungsrechts zeit ist auf der
strecke dazwischen muss es konkreter
dran und insbesondere des parlamentes
diese entscheidung treffen und diese ist
dabei jetzt bei uns und da sollten wir
jetzt haben nicht bis 2022 noch in
dieser legislaturperiode die hatten ja
das ist ein ambitioniertes ziel
herr jung angesichts der tatsache dass
er schon quasi im wahlkampf sind armin
laschet der parteivorsitzender der cdu
spricht von einem historischen moment
und markus söder der csu chef fordert
nun eine generalrenovierung des
klimaschutzgesetzes und zwar sowohl in
bayern als auch im bund wie soll denn
das im bund aussehen was ist denn jetzt
das gebot der stunde
das gebot der stunde ist
neben den weg nach 2030 konkreter zu
beschreiben
das kann jetzt in dem klimaschutzgesetz
noch nachgebessert werden in dieser
legislaturperiode
wir haben ja gerade in corona zweitens
parlament handlungsfähigkeit bewiesen
gezeigt dass wir in sehr kurzer zeit
entscheidung treffen können dass das
eine und es weiter was in diesem urteil
nicht schlecht was aber übrigens wegen
den höheren eu ziehen sowieso notwendig
ist wir müssen auch auf dem weg bis 2030
noch mal nachlegen
ich bleibe ja ausdrücklich dafür dass
wir den weg den wir gemeinsam bestritten
beschritten haben
dennis denen der co2 preise dass wir den
gibt nachschärfen da ist es richtig dass
wir moderat einstecken es ist richtig
dass es in etappen machen aber die
schritte müssen jetzt größere auf dem
weg schon bis 20.30 und es ist der
konkrete weitergehen auch diese
regierung leisten können darüber sollten
wir jetzt sprechen ja sie sagen die
schritte müssen größer werden und es
muss schneller gehandelt werden
jetzt sitzen sie ja schon länger in
berlin an den an er macht warum haben
sie denn in letzter zeit ich meine die
zahlen liegen ja nicht seit gestern vor
warum haben sie da nicht rascher
gehandelt ihr koalitionspartner wirft
ihnen ja vornehmlich dem
wirtschaftsminister altmaier sieht nur
auf der bremse gestanden
er ist hier nicht richtig und ich bin
bei aller kritik und andere
notwendigkeit jetzt anzugehen
doch noch mal erinnern an das jahr 2019
darstellt ja irgendwie erreichen ins
klimaziele nicht im jahr 2020
deshalb haben wir dort nachgeschärft
jetzt haben wir sie auch an corona es
liegt aber auch daran dass dieses paket
das wir auf den weg gebracht haben wirkt
ist klimaschutzgesetz verabschiedet und
wir sind jetzt in einer neuen phase
weniger als deutsche mitgewirkt an der
erhöhung des klimaziels haben wir
bereits in den letzten monaten auf den
weg gebracht wir haben es aus der
unionsfraktion heraus auch unterstützt
und er war immer klar
wenn die eu das ziel erhöht denn hat
konsequenzen für deutschland
dann kann und muss die eu mehr machen
zum beispiel über den emissionshandel
für strom und für industrie aber auch
wir müssen dann mehr machen wir müssen
unser klima ziel für 2030 erwünschen
wegen den europäischen entscheidungen
werde mich zu beginn der woche schon
jetzt ausdrücklich dafür ausgesprochen
jetzt müssen wir das angehen und diese
dinge in dieser regierung in dieser
legislaturperiode auf den weg bringen
ist weil ja paradox wenn wir es alle
sagen wir müssen mehr tun aber
gleichzeitig meinen würde das kann man
in den nächsten ferien immer nein wir
sind gewählt werden um die dinge die
gemacht werden können auf den weg zu
bringen
dafür haben wir noch die zeit und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt mit hochdruck
der 1
ja sie machen druck dafür habe ich ein
gewisses verständnis sie wollen ja auch
das umsetzen oder müssen als politiker
auch das umsetzen was da an an regeln
und als vorgaben nun aus karlsruhe kommt
aber herr jung heißt das nicht auch dass
man auch jetzt im wahlkampf den menschen
die wahrheit sagen muss den reduzierung
von co2-emissionen
das heißt ja nicht nur reduzierung in
der industrie oder beim autoverkehr oder
in der landwirtschaft sondern auch bei
den häusern das heißt da muss eine masse
eingespart werden da muss eine masse
geld reingesteckt werden und das werden
die mieter und die hausbesitzer doch
spüren würde es nicht zur wahrheit
gehören auch da klartext zu reden
wir reden der klartext der haben ja
schon mit der co2 preise und ein weg
beschritten mit dem der sein
wir steigen die preise das heißt es in
der mobilität und in den gebäuden bei
der wärme die preise für werden fossile
energien hat deshalb machen im übrigen
habe auch die form und die förderung
wenn er mir immer das verständnis
entwickelt und umgesetzt das ist ein
klimaschutz jahr müssen die menschen
mitnehmen deshalb fordern wir den
heizungs austausch deshalb die steuerung
für die gebäudesanierung die sadc
aufbringen für öko-autos das ist ja ein
ganz starkes instrument in der
klimapolitik das muss man es auch
nochmal
verstärken wenn wir gleichzeitig seien
die schritte werden schneller du musst
nicht darauf einrichten dass benzin das
heizöl schrittweise toller wird das
gehört mir sie sagen zur wahrheit dazu
und ich bin sehr dafür dass wir mit das
hinaus was wir jetzt tun können in
dieser legislaturperiode ganz klar in
unserem gemeinsamen wahlprogramm der
union festlegen
wir verfolgen das 15 grad sie wollen die
klimaneutralität erreichen
wir wollen ein glaubwürdiges konzept das
auf innovationen setzt und auf diesem
weg klimaschutz in einem industrieland
so recht dass man die menschen auch im
ländlichen raum auch dort wo sie am auf
mobilität angewiesen sind mit dem das
was wir konkret aus turnieren sein was
bedeutet es was kommt auf den einzelnen
zu nur dann als glaubwürdig und dann
kann man auch dafür einstehen der für
werbung und ja wir sind gespannt auf
ihre konzepte das war ein reaktion der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der union im deutschen bundestag ich
sage danke für ihre zeit und einen
schönen tag noch
ebenso hat sich in den